Hi guys, today we're going to go golfing
but I can't go like this because I look like an idiot
There we go, now let's go
[Camera-dude is Brooks. Grace added captions so I'll try to indicate who's talking]
[G]
In an on-going attempt to broaden my horizons and experience all aspects of life
I'm genuinely going to try to play golf to the best of my abilities today
I don't have clubs
We're not going to a high-end area, Thank God
We are going to a medium to low end area
course, golf course. We are going to a golf course. Of course.
It's nine holes
We're going to a par 3 but you obviously know what that means
We're in the jungle now. Oh my god. Oh my God. East side of LA is dangerous
Par 3 means that most people, it takes them three hits to get it in the hole
I'm going to say my score is gonna be...
That's my prediction. I'm going to try. I already am sweating
This outfit: great in theory
Not awesome in practice thus far
Go sports
Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow
[B]
[G]
*suck on my balls balls*
no one knows
[G]
[B]
[G]>>
*Don't you wish your girlfriend was--*
We're at the glory hole. The final hole.
It's a golf term for the final hole in a golf game
[B]
[G]
Whoa!
Doesn't matter I won YAY GOLF
I don't like this part of golf